many new ideas people won't believe and
they did when things are really new yeah
then there's frequently people know they
don't think that would work but I
started working on it with a student for
his PhD thesis we had worked on it for a
couple years and two of my very famous
colleague came in one of them already
had a Nobel Prize and was chillin had
been chillin Department the other was
going to get a Nobel Prize later and he
was chairman at that time they came into
my office and they said no you know
Charlie that's not going to work that's
not going to work you're really wasting
universities money and you really have
to stop well I was I was an associate
professor then and that means that they
could not fire me I had what we call
tenure they could even though the
Chairman apart I shouldn't know I think
it has a reasonable chance of working
and well I walk out my room angry and
yeah that's that's crazy well about
three months we had it working and one
of them even apologized to me well I
guess you know more about what you're
doing and than I do